the main conclusion of this afternoon
session was that we stand fully resolved
that we will always stand for our values
Europe has been under attack before but
we've always defended Liberty democracy
and we will do that we'll do that
together for that we adopted a
declaration in the afternoon which
emphasizes that we will exchange
information even swifter than we already
do that we will now very soon need to
implement the passenger named records we
will need to see a swift completion of
legislation on combating terrorism so we
don't need new plans we need to fully
execute the plans that have been the
measures that have been taken before and
decided upon before and the strong
result of the meeting is afternoon ones
to do that all European ministers the
Commission and European Parliament
together with us insisted on the swift
acting of the European institutions on
the different points of action of our
joint declaration and I only would like
to underline several some points of it
which are really in our view in the
Belgian view very important that is
first the interoperability of databases
which is really necessary would regard
to for instance the Schengen information
system but with regard to a lot of
example given Interpol databases we
really have to act swiftly on that issue
another issue which was very important
is the full exchange of judicial
information every day we discover in the
framework of what happened in bearers
and in Brussels how important it is that
our intelligence services that our
judicial services exchange all relevant
information that is required this
terrible this horrendous attacks cannot
continue to be wake-up calls forever we
owe this to our citizens all of them so
what
do we need to do in the coming days in
the coming weeks to prevent as much as
possible this type of events to happen
again two essential elements first
improve on our exchange of information
and second implement put in practice
what was politically agreed after
previous attacks remember from last
December our agreement on PNR why is it
still in place parliament has to vote to
adopt it and this has to happen now to
those that wish to divide us we respond
with unity resilience and determination
as our meeting demonstrates today and
this is a very strong message we want to
send from this meeting because it is
what we stand for as Europeans